- [Illustrator] Did you
know that communication
is actually one of the most
important things in science?
As we discover cool things,
we need to be able to
share them with others.
And when we're talking
about data and measurements
with other scientists,
we need to make sure
we're on the same page.
So how do we do that?
Well, one of the ways is to use units.
We use units whenever we talk
about things like position,
where an object is located,
how long it is, it's mass,
how much matter it's made
up of or it's motion.
How is that object moving?
You probably hear units every day.
For example, you've grown,
let's say an inch and a
half in the past year,
or that tree over there is 25 feet tall.
And maybe you went swimming
in a 25 meter pool.
And we're just gonna pretend
that the pool is a rectangle
because as you can tell from my tree,
my artistic skills are not that great.
Anyway, this brings up
a super important point
about why we use units.
I just used three examples
of length measurements
with three different units,
inches, feet, and meters.
Imagine if I didn't attach a unit
to any of these measurements,
you grew one and a half, what? Meters?
Whoa, one and a half hands.
Well, whose hands?
Your hands or my hands?
Woof, well, pretend those are hands.
Units let us know how much
of a quantity there is.
So a meter is always
used to measure length
and we know exactly how long a meter is.
That way when we say
something is two meters long,
no one has to guess at how big that is.
Any measurement or data point
always needs to have a unit
or else it's just a meaningless number.
To avoid any confusion,
in science we use what
are called SI units.
SI units are the International System.
Could there be any more
letters in this word system
used by scientists all over the world.
We'll use meters to
describe position or length,
kilograms for mass,
and if we're talking about
the motion of something,
meters per second.
And while this is the agreed
upon scientific unit system,
you should be aware that
other systems do exist,
which means things can very
easily get very confusing
if you forget your units.
And you might be thinking,
"Oh, come on, who mixes up units?'
Well, it happens more
often than you think,
even rocket scientists have done it.
I mean, a Mars Orbiter actually crashed
due to a mix up in units.
Now seriously, that actually happened,
look it up and remember to use your units.